هل كان رئيس الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي
مريضا في السنوات الاخيره هل كان يعاني من
امراض معينه تؤثر على وظيفته لم يكن مريضا
يعني
هل تراجع اداؤه بسبب سنه في السنوات
الاخيره
فقط بحكم الثورات التي حصلت هل كان ذلك
الى حد ما
توصيف في السنوات الاخيره مقبول همم بمعنى
انه محيط نفسه بشخصيات معينه تقول له تنقل
له ما تريد ويسمع الى ما تقوله ولا يعرف
حقيقه ما يحدث في الشارع
ذلك هو انا انت في سؤالك
ذكرت ان بحكم الثورات وما اسميته بالثورات
كنا نتحدث عنهم
فقط يعني وهم زائد ما هي قصه الثورات لان
لم يكن من عليا نتحدث كان على رئيس
الولاده عليه كان يتابع على اوضاع في
البلاد ويعرف الصعوبات ويعيش الاذان
ويتفاعل معها وفعلا كما قلت انا منذ حين
عايزنا الكثير من الازمات والتفاعلنا معها
ونجح تونس في ذلك همم
ماذا حقت التغيرات التي سارت بعد 2021
يعني حريه التعبير صحيح
ولكن نزلت مكوسه في حاله مجالات
ولكن عمليا واجتماعيا واقتصاديا وحتى
سياسيا
الدستور الذي الغي في 25 جويليه 21 لما
يكون دستورا صالحا رغم ان منسوق قالوا انه
افضل الدستور في الدنيا